did you know that between the official
trailer and artwork there are already
more than
10 confirmed magical creatures for
hogwarts legacy
and we're going to go through each one
of them right now people of the
internet's retro reckons who are here
if we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories
they tell we post videos every week here
on youtube and also stream over on
twitch
today we have another hogwarts legacy
video and this one is all about the
magical creatures
so far we only have two official sources
to pull from one being the official
trailer and the second
being the official wallpaper we're also
going to talk about the implications
of these creatures being in the game
because i think they actually give us
quite a bit of info into some of the
gameplay
details being planned for hogwarts
legacy speaking of magical creatures
though let me know a few that you'd like
to see in the game and i'll make another
video featuring some of the top picks
alright for today we'll start with the
trailer and then make our way over to
the wallpaper which actually has a few
that
aren't seen in the trailer so first up
here we have
moon calves these little guys have pale
grey fur and only come out during the
full moon
our pal newt's commander kept a herd of
moon caps in his briefcase while
visiting new york in 1926.
a little humorous factoid here about
mooncaps is they have this
mating ritual where they perform a
series of dance moves now these dance
moves actually leave
patterns in the fields and of course
muggles are just completely baffled as
to what these patterns actually are
by the way all the info on our magical
creatures today is courtesy of
the harry potter wiki which i will be
sure to link to down in the description
below
as far as the gameplay implications go i
think the fact that these guys
only come out during the full moon just
about confirms that we'll have some sort
of day night system in place
then when you specifically consider the
fact that it's only during a
full moon maybe this is a good
indication we'll see seasonal weather
changes as well
which is something a lot of you have
been asking for next up we have
hippogriffs which any long time harry
potter fan should know
well hippogriffs appeared on both the us
and uk covers of harry potter and the
prisoner of azkaban
of course buckbeak the hippogriff played
a prominent role throughout the book and
helped sirius black make his escape
not only does the trailer confirm
hippogriffs though it also confirms
we'll actually be able to
ride on the hippogriffs which is a
fantastic confirmation to get
this early the question for me is if
this is only in a specific
mission or if this is more of a free
roam mechanic similar to your horse in a
game like
zelda or the witcher it's not all
peaceful and happy creatures though
because the trailer also shows a shot of
inferior
as well as dementors now to be fair here
technically these two
aren't considered magical creatures at
least with how the wizarding world
classifies
magical creatures and fury are basically
reanimated corpses while dementors are
actually
considered non-beings that being said i
still think it fits here and think it's
worth
discussing them here
when it comes to the in fury i've seen a
lot of speculation around the cave that
harry and dumbledore visit to retrieve
slytherin's locket
in harry potter and the half-blood
prince there's just one problem here
though
it was actually voldemort who placed
those in fury there and he used his
victims from the first wizarding war
if it's anywhere close to 1899 then it's
possible these and fury were created
by grindelwald it's believed grindelwald
sought to create an army of inferior so
it's entirely possible that he had at
least
started experimenting with that idea the
dementors are another well-known entity
from the mainline series
maybe the most interesting part here is
that seeing a dementor would be a strong
indication that our journey may
take us to azkaban prison in fact this
shot right here of the trailer this
actually looks like azkaban to me if you
remember from prisoner of azkaban it was
actually a really big deal when the
dementors were brought to hogwarts and
something that dumbledore staunchly
opposed
so they could make a return to hogwarts
for some related reason but i would
actually guess that our journey takes us
to azkaban at some point
graph horns also make an appearance in
the trailer and we see them both
docile and hostile which is no surprise
given that avalanche has confirmed we'll
be able to tame certain magical
creatures
graph horns are considered to be very
aggressive and quite dangerous
they live in the mountains and have skin
stronger than that of dragons which is
capable of repelling most spells
during the late 1800s grab horns should
be increasingly
rare as they were coming very close to
extinction by 1926 newt scamander was in
possession of the last pair of breeding
grab horns
up next we have trolls not really much
to say here they appear to be serving a
similar role to the one they served in
the first harry potter book
trolls were really known for two things
their immense strength
and immense stupidity the trailer also
shows a massive
dragon and it appears we'll be getting
up close and personal with it during our
journey through hogwarts legacy
if we take a look at the features of the
dragon we'll see it has a few defining
characteristics
first off we see the horns around its
face from this official screenshot it
actually looks like five
horns with three on top and then two
down on the bottom around the mouth
when it takes flight at the end of the
trailer we can freeze it here to see a
sharp tail with these little
spikes on the end kind of looks like an
arrow if you read through the fantastic
beast's description of dragons this one
doesn't really fit 100
with any of them at least i don't think
so i don't think it's a hungarian
horntail because they were known for
having spikes all along their back
maybe it's a norwegian ridgeback which
closely resembles a horntail except for
the spikes on the back
if i had to guess though i think i would
say it's a hybridian black dragon which
is native to britain
the main reason for that guess is
because these dragons are known to have
a tail
tipped with an arrow-shaped spike they
also have brilliant purple eyes
admittedly the eyes do look red to me in
the screenshot however they definitely
appear more purple in the trailer of
course there's always a chance that it's
a breed we've never even heard of as
well
the question for me why is a dragon
hanging out so close to hogwarts
before we jump to the wallpaper i should
also point out we see two of the three
animals which students are allowed to
bring to hogwarts as
pets we see both a cat as well as an owl
in the trailer
i have to say guys i never really
understood the appeal of choosing a toad
as your hogwarts pet
especially over an owl or a cat but
anyway for all the toad lovers out there
hopefully avalanche will heal your cries
and have them in the game as well
and again strictly speaking here i guess
these aren't magical creatures they're
just normal everyday animals but they do
play a prominent role as we know
in the wizarding world now as for the
wallpaper we do see the dragon yet again
looming
very close to hogwarts there's also
another grab horn on the bottom left
side of the wallpaper
one interesting note here is this one
appears to have a smaller grab horn
traveling along with it
also on the top right we see yet another
owl carrying the mail and you can also
make out the owlery here in the distance
in addition there are two other magical
creatures shown here in the wallpaper
that actually
aren't in the trailer on the bottom
right we can make out these little pink
owl-like creatures known as
whoopers don't let their innocent
appearance fool you though
floopers have a high pitched song that
can actually drive the listener
insane in fact any of these birds that
were sold had to have a
silencing charm placed on them first the
charm had to be renewed
monthly and anyone wanting to own one of
these birds had to have a license to do
so
and then we have what is easily the most
well hidden creature on the wallpaper
and that is a giant
spider you can see it here just above
the floopers and a little bit to the
right
it blends in almost perfectly with the
surrounding terrain
and you guys know if giant spiders are
in the game then that all but guarantees
we're going to have some missions that
take place
in the forbidden forest too bad we won't
have mr weasley's ford anglia to help us
out and guys actually after recording
all that original i
found there is a spider in the trailer
as well
you can see it right here after this
spell is cast
so not only will we be having giant
spiders in the game we'll also be having
the
tiny baby spiders as well if you guys
are new here and you haven't seen our
other hogwarts legacy videos i'm gonna
throw a playlist up here on the right
side of your screen
check those out when you have time and
as always guys and gals thank you so
much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon